time then for sunday nights press
preview a first look at what is on
monday's front pages and tonight we'll
check out the headlines with deputy
online editor of the new statesman
rachel cunliffe and deputy political
editor of the daily mail john stevens
good to see you both we'll chat in a
moment first of all let's go through
those papers for you starting with the
telegraph looking at boris johnson's new
get boosted now campaign offering a
third jab to every eligible adult in
england by the new year
the guardian also leads with the prime
minister's vaccination plans their
headline pm bets on 1 million jabs a day
to halt tidal wave of omicron
boris's million jabs a day booster
rocket reads the front of the daily mail
the sun also covers mr johnson's plans
to get boost vaccines for every adult by
the end of the year
here's your metro leading with more than
half a million booster jabs being
delivered on a single record-breaking
day
in the race to head off a rapid rise in
cases of the new covid variant
in the ft meanwhile ukraine's new
defence minister blames germany for
blocking the supply of weapons to kiev
through nato
and i'm joined tonight by rachel
cunliffe and john stevens great to see
you all the front pages quite
understandably talking about that
address to the nation by the prime
minister and john
downey street only press that button
don't they when things have got very
serious and from the prime minister's
language uh he was talking about uh this
tidal wave of omicron it was it was
dramatic wasn't it and it was stark
yeah it was definitely a shift of
language there from the prime minister
they did talk about tidal wave he talked
about how we're facing an emergency and
obviously it's quite unusual to see the
prime minister giving a speech to nation
late on a sunday evening
the government clearly think that they
really need to get the boosted program
going and i think the problem has been
the last few weeks it's obviously a
couple of weeks since the government
announced that they're going to extend
boosters to all over 18s but we haven't
really seen a massive improvement in the
number of people getting them it's only
yesterday that we saw more than half a
million people getting the covid vaccine
booster and so i think the mission now
for the government is trying to really
get this out there most of the front
pages seem to talk about a million jabs
a day that need to be given i think
there is a big question mark about
whether they're going to be able to do
that especially once you've got
christmas right in the middle of that
period so it looks like quite a tough
art yeah front page of the guardian uh
same picture of the prime minister
recording that address pm bets on 1
million jabs a day to halt tidal wave of
omicron rachel it is going to be a huge
task to get this done isn't it a massive
mission the prime minister did give some
detail about how it was going to be
achieved but also a warning that people
who are waiting for appointments may be
disappointed and of course that's just
going to add more misery onto
record-breaking waiting lists
so that was quite striking the
announcement from the prime minister
that gps will be expected to basically
stop doing the appointments that they've
been doing uh non-urgent treatments will
be halted and that obviously a lot of
these non-urgent treatments are
procedures that people have already been
waiting months or even years for um but
the the reason for doing that is to put
the all the nhs capacity into the
booster rollout by bringing the target
date to have all adults get their
booster uh forward from the end of
january to the end of december i think
like what's interesting about the the
point about gps and nhs treatment is
that uh
nhs or hospital emergency rooms are
already under tremendous strain at the
moment we've done some exclusive
reporting at the new statesman about the
crisis in uh ambulances not being able
to hand over patients into a e
department because those departments are
full and therefore people calling out
for an ambulance and the ambulances
don't arrive because they can't take
them now if
in order to get the booster roll out
meeting those targets what you end up
doing is
stopping or halting a lot of primary
care you're going to get more people
going to the emergency room because
that's the only way that they can get
any treatment at all so you are in a way
trying to take off pressure from the nhs
on on one hand but actually uh just
piling on that pressure somewhere else
obviously this is in the winter when
there are more people turning up to a e
for all kinds of reasons so i think it's
going to be a very difficult to run up
to christmas for the health service to
try and prioritize this and make sure
that people with with non-covered
related uh injuries or illnesses still
get the treatment that they need
john just looking at the front of the
metro 530 086 boosters done in one day
that is
pretty remarkable we know the prime
minister's credibility has been uh
uh really knocked in the last few days
do you think that will affect uh this
push to get people to have their
boosters or do you think they're more
worried about saving christmas
i hope not i think most people are
sensible enough to know that whatever is
going on with boris johnson
that you listen to the house experts if
you're not willing to listen to the
prime minister and they've been clear
that if you have two doses of the
vaccine they don't really work as well
against omicron i think the
effectiveness goes down to
about 30
whereas if you get the three vaccines
you have your booster as well your
effectiveness it goes back up to about
70 to 75
so i think if boris johnson was bringing
more and more restrictions i think
that's a harder ask because you'd have
people saying hang on a minute you're
asking me to make sacrifices whilst
people in number 10 didn't back last
year but when it comes to the vaccine i
think most people know that this is our
best way out of this pandemic and if
it's a choice between getting your
booster jack and having with more
restrictions in the new year i think
most people would pick getting their
booster job now yeah i mean i could i
suppose let's ask the question in a
slightly different way we know there's
this huge vote rachel uh in the commons
many rebels are unhappy about these
further restrictions do you think the
seriousness of the prime minister's tone
tonight could persuade them otherwise
no not at all and actually i think that
there are the cynical perspective would
be why do a prime ministerial
pre-recorded address uh like he did to
announce something that which we've all
known is coming we've heard about the
booster rollout uh in in in the previous
days why make such a big deal out of it
if it wasn't to try it at least in part
to get the front pages about that rather
than about the the christmas party
revelations and the rule breaking that
we've had over the past week so i i
don't think there's going to be a sense
that oh we all have to trust boris
johnson now we tory mps or wii umps
because we're in a serious crisis i
think that the the feeling will be we
are in a serious crisis and therefore
the prime minister's
uh
inability to handle a crisis shall we
say in a diplomatic way
becomes even more important and i think
even if we if we put aside the christmas
party issue for the moment there is a
real question about competence when it
comes to the timing of this as as we've
been saying the booster rollout is
something that has been being talked
about for a while the government didn't
get underway with it until basically too
late the the website in order to book a
vacci nhs vaccine has been completely
crippled tonight you can't get on it at
all we've now got 18 days to do 18
million doses there is a real sense that
the government could have made a start
on this earlier and didn't possibly
because the prime minister was too busy
wondering about how to handle the
christmas party story rather than
dealing with the real issues on the
ground okay um it sort of leads us on to
the front of the daily telegraph pyramid
talks to hire uh the election guru sir
linton uh crosby um are those
accusations fair do you think john
well i think the accusation that they've
been problems in downing street that's
quite clear but i'm not sure that's
really hindered the booster rollout in
the last couple of weeks i think
you know you've got the nhs working away
beaving away on getting that up and
running i think more of the criticism is
why we didn't get on with the booster
program in the last couple of months you
look at the graph of how many vaccines
were given a day and it went way down to
about 58 000 jabs a day being given in
september
and even though we didn't know that the
omicron variant was going to come along
we did know that there were going to be
a dip in the effectiveness of the
vaccines after a few months had passed
and so a question is why did we dither
around for so long deciding whether we
were going to give boosters to over 18s
or not it's something we've been talking
about for months and months
but instead we're only just getting
round to it i think those pop-up
vaccine clinics have been set up that
were doing so well at the start of the
year and through the summer
it's not really clear why they got kind
of all shut up and shunted away and now
all of a sudden we have to open up all
again yeah it feels like we're going
back to momentum um right at the start
of the the vaccination program okay
thank you both rachel front of the ft
and uh rather depressing signal of how
long the government think the pandemic
could uh still be an issue
yes these are uh contracts with
consultancy firms like deloitte and
accenture which we know the government
uses quite a lot to get their covered uh
things done uh suggesting that the track
and trade test and trace system uh might
be in place or is expected to be in
place uh until 2025 and also travel
restrictions uh in some way the green
amber and red list also for the next
couple of years so all of the focus
right now is obviously on the omicron
variant and on saving christmas but just
a reminder though on the ft that we are
well
if it's 2025 we're not even halfway
through this so marathon rather than a
sprint depressing news something to push
off into the future i don't know it's
it's not it's not the most uplifting
reading is it really isn't john is it
it's um you know something that uh we
all know don't we i think in the heart
of hearts we've got to to live with this
in some shape uh or form as as we move
ahead
yeah definitely and i think
most people are hoping that we were
coming to the end of this in some way i
mean
i guess one positive is that we can cope
with test and trace still being around
we can cope with having our travel
monitored if we're coming back into the
country having to fill in forms etc but
i think if you had restrictions staying
for a long time then i think that's when
you start to get people
really frustrated i think people are
longing for the time when we don't have
to have masks on the tube etc
and a lot of businesses obviously hoping
that they start to pick up their
business and don't have this constant
going to and fro between restrictions
which obviously been massively damaging
for them
yeah and um just moving on to a
completely different story away from
covid uh the guardian uh talking about
those awful tornadoes in the united
states rachel five states really
struggling uh in the aftermath and the
guardian focusing on the on the climate
angle
yeah so firstly pointing out that deaths
in kentucky will exceed 100 so this is a
real um serious and tragic event but the
climate angle here is important
as climate change continues this was
mentioned in in in copper it was a big
theme of copper we've all kind of
forgotten about it these freak weather
events these once in a hundred years
once in 200 years weather events will
become increasingly common and we're
going to have to learn to deal with the
consequences of that as well so once
we've dealt with the clover disaster
then we've got climate change and uh and
frequently this is really not not a
positive evening to do the paper review
is that i know i'm really sorry about it
we're going to have to do better john
aren't we in the next hour to find
something uplifting in all the in all
the doom and gloom
yeah definitely and you look at those
pictures i think they were just running
on the screen of those towns in kentucky
i mean that main town that got hit it's
just incredible you just look straight
after street after street utter carnage
just completely destroyed the buildings
look like they're
completely gone and one of the places it
was a candle factory i think there were
about 100 work people
working there about 40 of them have been
rescued
and rescued
still still on going i'm going to have
to stop you john i'm so sorry